with in 1975 with x-ray crystallography
of transfer RNA and seeing how that how
that affects the carrying of
instructions to other parts of the cell
that was kind of a big moment for you
and that was at the cutting edge of
knowledge and you've spent the next 40
years at the cutting edge plus years at
the cutting edge of knowledge always
pushing always pushing the edge of what
we know tell us about that it's not just
knowledge there's also engineering but
yet the transfer RNA that was teenager
was first introduced to this research
project
my son Koh Kim and his team and I was
doing I started I was just a job but it
was one that I picked I mean I didn't
you know to be the fusion of math
physics chemistry biology computer
science all in one package because you
really had to have all of those two it's
not like looking through a microscope or
you just see things you actually have to
solve the structure but it also
introduced me to whole world of nucleic
acids and I you know the Epiphany of
typing in all of the sequences that were
known at the time the one dimensional
structures folding over the three
dimensions and then seeing how this is
how easy that was and and how valuable
it would be to have the one dimensional
structure of everything in the world it
also introduced me to automation so we
had all that data was automatically
collected this in 1974 and almost
nothing was computerized or automated in
the rest of the rest of biology and I
thought well time to introduce that and
there were many other aspects of it you
know first folded RNA first folding to
click acid it was
led me to a lot of almost everything
we're still working on has to do with
that and we still work on even
transforming itself in the genetic code
changing genetic codes yeah number of
organisms now